am 23 07 2014 war es soweit in kleinen
tellern der hochebene in der östlichen
antarktis wurde der extremste
kälterekord gemessen minus 98,6 grad
celsius waren es damals in der
polarnacht eisiger kann es wohl auf der
erdoberfläche auch nicht werden da sind
sich forschungsteams sicher hier zu
atmen würde lebensgefahr bedeuten
bronchien und lungen gefäße würden
verkrampfen
doch das ist nicht der einzig wirklich
extreme ort auf dieser welt wurde auf
der erde regnet es sind 37 jahren nur
viermal
und wo ist der wind so stark dass man
ihnen nicht mal messen kann die top-5
extremst orte auf der erde jetzt den
blick zum science fiction hier gibt's
täglich science videos abonniert den
kanal dann verpasst der kein okay let's
go herzlich willkommen den bisherigen
kälterekord hatten satelliten messungen
der nasa an einem eher drücken in der
nähe von dome argus einer hochebene in
der antarktis gemessen minus 93,2 grad
celsius wurden hier am 10 august 2010
gemessen
dort sind es also knapp 50 grad kälter
als in sibirien die krasse keller
entstand wohl durch die große höhe über
dem meeresspiegel gepaart mit einem
wolkenfreien mit doch dieser rekord ist
jetzt geschichte wie neue auswertung der
sozialisten messung zeigt und 98,6 grad
am 23.7 2014 war unglaublich das
forschungsteam aussehen usa erklärt die
besonders krasse kälte mit mehreren
faktoren die wohl zu diesem zeitpunkt
zusammen kamen zum einen kann die wärme
ohne wolken direkt vom höhenrücken ins
all steigen zudem kalte luft ist
schwerer als warme so war sie wohl
angetrieben durch die schwerkraft in
diese senken gerutscht hinzu kamen nach
angaben der forscher und forscherinnen
außerdem eine extrem trockene luft so
dass die wärme der schneeoberfläche
leichter ins alt treten konnte einen
kleinen wermutstropfen gibt es dennoch
die weltorganisation für meteorologie
zeigt sich unbeeindruckt und erkennt
diese neuen rekord kälte nicht an da sie
direkt auf dem eis gemessen wurden und
eben nicht in der luft ihre ansicht nach
liegt der rekord bei minus 89,2 grad
celsius diese temperatur wurde im juli
983 in der arktis gemessen übrigens der
kälteste dauerhaft bewohnte ort der erde
liegt in der sibirischen siegling bäumen
ya konan
winter sind es dort bis zu minus 67,8
grad celsius im sommer dagegen das
krasse gegenteil dann können es auch mal
30 grad und mehr wert platz 4 der
trockenste ort der welt perfektes
testgebiet für den mars rover das
wirklich kaum vorstellbar selbst für
diejenigen unter euch die regen
verabscheuen in einer bestimmten region
der atacama wüste in chile richtet ist
nur viermal und das in 37 jahren in die
anden blocken jegliche niederschläge ab
also das gibt dort geht es so
unvorstellbar trocken dass die nasa die
region 216 als perfektes testgebiet für
den mars rover erklärt hat zwar ist es
hier mit mehr als 100 grad mehr deutlich
wärmer als auf dem mars aber dennoch ist
sich die boden beschaffung ziemlich
ähnlich deswegen hat die nasa hier auch
beispielsweise einige bohr technologien
getestet die zukünftig auch auf dem mars
angewendet werden könnten zudem wurden
auch proben gesammelt um diese im labor
auf extreme mikroorganismen zu
analysieren in der gesamten
atacama-wüste herrscht wasserarmut also
die trockenste wüste der welt als das
gilt sicher doch trotzdem leben hier in
den sehr seltenen rasen auch einige
wenige menschen platz 3 der wichtigste
ort der welt windböen bis zu 240
kilometer pro stunde hier gucken wir wie
auch beim platz fünf in die antarktis
denn hier gibt es ganz besondere winde
wie dem kathartischen wind zb
vereinfacht gesagt ist das ein
konzentrierter strom aus eisiger luft
ein sogenannter fallwind der
folgendermaßen entsteht unter einer
eisfläche etwa eines gletschers oder
eines gebirges kühlt sich die luft ab
und deren dichte nimmt zu es entsteht
eine druckausgleich strömung an
eröffnung dann natürlich mit der wärme
und umgebung und der besonders kalte
kathartische fallwind entsteht nur 12
bis 19 13 hat sie sich ein
forschungsteam dorthin begeben und hatte
die 48 kilometer breite bucht entdeckt
dabei hatte das thema auf versucht die
windgeschwindigkeit amt dennis an der
spitze der kammer im osten der antarktis
zu messen dazu der expeditionsleiter von
damals das klima erwies sich das ganze
jahr hindurch als ein ununterbrochener
schneesturm und tatsächlich geschaltet
ist sich auch heutzutage noch schwer die
stärke der kadaver zwischen winde zu
messen die extra
den starken winde in kombination mit den
temperaturen unter null grad celsius
machen den empfindlichen messgeräten zu
schaffen und so schaffte es die bucht
ins guinness buch der rekorde als
winzigster ort der welt ihre
durchschnittliche windgeschwindigkeit
liegt demnach bei 80 kilometern pro
stunde im durchschnitt die maximale
windgeschwindigkeit ist mit 240
kilometern pro stunde angegeben
kaum vorstellbar dass hier tiere oder
menschen leben umso kurioser dass wir
vor allem kaiserpinguine und andere
pinguinarten eines ihrer wichtigsten
brutgebieten platz zwei der nächste ort
der welt man sieht die hand vor augen
nicht zu den düstersten orten der welt
gehören wohl die great banks vor der
küste neufundlands rund 200 tage projekt
gibt es hier so krass nebel dass man gar
nichts mehr sieht alles ist nur noch
grau und verschwommen der grund der
warme golfstrom aus dem süden und der
kalte labrador strom aus dem norden
treffen aufeinander
die kühlere luftmassen können wenig
wasserdampf aufnehmen sodass dieser
kondensiert dabei entsteht nebel platz
eins der heißeste ort der welt dennoch
existiert hier leben mit platz eins
schließen wir den kreis begonnen haben
wir mit dem kälterekord also schauen wir
jetzt na logisch auf den heißesten ort
dieser welt in der ludwig im iran
befindet sich wohl der hitzepol der erde
und zwar mit rund 70 grad celsius plus
2005 wurde hier mit einem infrarot
radiometer des satelliten aqua die
bodentemperatur ermittelt diese extreme
hitze macht diesen ort zu einem eher
lebensfeindlichen raum doch ein
forschungsteam hat hier tatsächlich
leben gefunden skorpione zum beispiel
die sich an die extremen verhältnisse
angepasst haben sie ernähren sich vom
tod genauer genommen von verirrten
zugvögeln die in der heißen wüstenluft
sterben und einfach vom himmel fallen
ein paar grad kälter sind es dagegen im
kalifornischen death valley das tal des
todes und doch gibt es hier leben obwohl
sich wohl so anfühlt wie ein backofen
von innen denn im jahr 2002 wurden hier
52,8 grad celsius gemessen und das ist
wissenschaftlich belegt nachts zeigte
das thermometer dann nur noch 37,8 grad
an menschen trifft man hier kaum nur ein
paar indianer und nationalpark ranger
leben hier ja und wenn ihr dieses video
spannend gefunden habt dann endet meine
telefonnummer whatsapp dann bekommt ihr
täglich vor allen andern
den link zum video von mir persönlich
und zur begrüßung gibt es ein kleines
geschenk einfach hier draufklicken und
da drunter drauf klicken
wenn ihr das video sehen wo im sommer
2018 klimawandel die erde überhitzt bis
dann bleibt dran